[Musique]
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui dans science clic les
mathématiques de la relativité générale
partie de vitesse spatio temporelle on
sait désormais décrire la position de la
pomme en terme de ces deux coordonnées
sur la grille comme on l'a vu on
interprète la ligne d'univers comme un
déplacement à mesure que s'écoule le
temps propre les coordonnées de la pomme
qui décrivent sa position vont évoluer
elles dépendent du temps propre et il
est donc intéressant de définir une
notion de vitesse la vitesse de la pomme
dans l'espace temps est une flèche un
vecteur tangent à la trajectoire dont
l'orientation épouser son mouvement la
longueur de cette flèche traduit la
vitesse du mouvement
cette longueur est la même partout car
les graduations de temps propres sont
régulièrement espacés sur la trajectoire
ce qui signifie qu'en l'espace d'un même
temps propre la pomme parcours toujours
la même distance
de façon plus générale tous les objets
de l'univers se déplace avec exactement
la même vitesse c'est une constante
universelle qu'on appelle la vitesse de
la lumière et que l'on désignera par la
lettre c
on peut alors écrire une toute première
équation fondamentale qui dit que la
longueur du vecteur vitesse sa norme est
toujours égale à la vitesse de la
lumière
[Musique]
lorsqu'on utilise d unité cohérente par
exemple si on mesure le temps en
secondes et les distances en seconde
lumière la vitesse de la lumière vos
précisément 1
cela signifie simplement que le temps
devient une mesure de distance le temps
propre d'un objet et simplement la
distance qu'ils parcourent dans l'espace
temps en l'espace d'une seconde de temps
propre la pomme se déplace d'une seconde
lumière dans l'espace temps on désire
maintenant décomposer le vecteur vitesse
en fonction des coordonnées pour se
faire à partir de l'album on trace deux
flèches sur la grille qui représente les
directions et amplitude de chacune des
deux corps donné ses flèches sont ce
qu'on appelle des vecteurs de base ont
les nôtres à deux héros et e1 en
fonction de l'accord donné qu'ils
décrivent à partir de ces deux vecteurs
de base on peut décomposer le vecteur
vitesse comme une somme ici par exemple
deux flèches bleues et une flèche rouge
les nombres 2 et 1 sont ce qu'on appelle
les composantes du vecteur vitesse la
valeur d'une composante mesurent la
vitesse à laquelle augmente l'accord
données associées
en quelque sorte on zoome sur la pomme
et on mesure le rythme auquel elles se
déplacent le long de chacune des deux
corps donnés au cours du temps propres
[Musique]
de façon plus générale on peut écrire
que le vecteur vitesse est la somme de
ses composantes x les vecteurs de base
associés
[Musique]
dans les expressions mathématiques en
relativité générale il arrive souvent
qu'on effectue la somme d'1 mêmes termes
appliqué à chaque coordonnée une par une
par exemple dans l'équation précédentes
on a écrit la vitesse comme la somme de
chaque composante x le vecteur de base
respectifs pour pouvoir compact eefje
cette écriture
on peut résumer la somme toute entière
en écrivant qu'un seul de ces termes et
en remplaçant le chiffre qui désigne la
coordonnées en question par une lettre
grecque par exemple alpha qui va
parcourir chaque coordonnée une par une
c'est ce qu'on appelle la notation de
nstein lorsqu'une lettre grecque et
répété deux fois une fois en haut et une
fois en bas il s'agit en réalité d'une
somme dans laquelle cette lettre grecs
désignent chaque coordonner une par une
pour finir illustrons ce concept de
vitesse spatio temporel à l'aide d'un
exemple concret on imagine un satellite
en orbite circulaire autour de la terre
lorsqu'on observe depuis une position
lointaine
le mouvement du satellite peut être
décrit à l'aide de deux coordonner le
temps que l'on mesure sur notre horloge
thé et un angle fille qui décrit la
position du satellite autour de la
planète
en analysant sa ligne d'univers on peut
tracer le vecteur vitesse du satellite
en chaque point
ce vecteur vitesse peut alors être
décomposé sur nos deux coordonnées la
première composante nous donne sa
vitesse temporel c'est le rythme auquel
s'écoule notre temps par rapport à son
temps propre
si cette valeur vos 2 cela signifie par
exemple qu'après chaque seconde de temps
propre qui s'écoule pour le satellite
notre temps se sera écoulé de deux
secondes la deuxième composante
représente sa vitesse angulaire
c'est le rythme auquel augmente l'angle
que forme le satellite autour de la
terre si cette composante vaut 10 degrés
par seconde
cela signifie par exemple qu'après
chaque seconde de temps propre
le satellite aura tourné de 10 degrés
autour de la terre la première des
équations qu'on a obtenus nous permet
d'affirmer que la longueur du vecteur
vitesse est toujours la même il s'agit
de la vitesse de la lumière
première vue on pourrait penser qu'il
suffit d'utiliser le théorème de
pythagore pour calculer la norme de la
vitesse à partir de ses composantes
mais il est très important de comprendre
que les coordonnées ne représentent pas
des distances concrète leur valeur et le
rythme auquel augmente sondés nombre
arbitraire qui n'ont pas réellement de
signification physique par exemple même
si l'angle que forment ces deux
satellites augmente au même rythme il
est facile d'observer que ce même rythme
ne correspond pas à la même vitesse
le satellite le plus loin se déplacent
le plus vite une même composante de
vitesse ne correspond pas en réalité à
la même vitesse physique dans les
prochaines vidéos
nous verrons comment résoudre ce
problème comment obtenir une vraie
mesure de la vitesse à partir de ses
composantes en construisant une nouvelle
version du théorème de pythagore plus
perfectionnés et plus général qui
fonctionne dans l'espace temps et pour
n'importe quelle grille
[Musique]
oh